we did a poll at the end of last year
and we asked people how important do you
think it is to reduce the influence of
money in politics ninety-six percent of
americans said it was important to
reduce the influence of money in
politics but then we asked him how
likely do you think it is that the
influence of money in politics will be
reduced and we found ninety-one percent
of americans believe it was not likely
now these two numbers 96% + 91 %
produced what we can think of as the
politics of resignation resignation we
accept the reality we don't want but if
you could give people some hope that
there was a way to make a change you
might be able to thaw that resignation
or at least that was the idea behind in
a project that I announced at Ted this
year called the May one project so may
one as in May Day which harmonizes well
with May Day as an emergency we wanted
to call a mayday on this democracy and
we wanted to announce a project to
launch a super PAC to end all super PACs
for the last year we've asked some
consultants to calculate how much would
it take to win a congress in 2016 that
would have the power that would have the
effect of passing fundamental reform how
much would that be and then we would
kickstart both from the bottom up and
then the top down enough to run that
campaign so the by election day in 2016
we would get the majorities in the house
as necessary to pass fundamental reform
the first step to reducing the influence
of money in politics then we do this in
two stages 2014 and 2016 and in 2014 the
idea is how do we raise 12 million
dollars to fund some races that would
give us the chance to affect
substantially the way people perceived
the possibility of winning on this issue
we said we would do this first by
raising a million dollars in 30 days
kickstart a million dollars in 30 days
and if we did that we would get that
matched
and then we would kickstart 5 million
dollars in 30 days and if we did that we
would get that matched and then we'd use
that to win in five districts and set
this foundation for 2016 and in 2016
we'd have to spend a god awful amount of
money we're not sure what that number is
yet but it's a really big amount of
money to win now you look at this yeah
well we you're using big money to end
big money and I get it it's kind of
ironic right but as Lincoln used to say
we had to be resolved and this is our
resolve to find a way to build this
government of By and For the People not
for the inks a government dependent on
the people alone and that's what we aim
for on may first we launched this
experiment this crazy idea of
kick-starting a million dollars in 30
days the first day and a half we had
raised more than 300,000 then the
servers melted we will today cross the
million-dollar line with two weeks left
on that initial goal now this is the
people caring pundits this is the people
caring more than 10,000 people have
signed up for this average contribution
is eighty-seven dollars 10,000 people
who are fed up with the way this system
functions and are willing to step up to
do something about it I get it when I
talk about this people say to me you
know can't really be this bad you're
being Cassandra esque but here's the
thing Cassandra was right she was right
and when I tell you about this
corruption you know I'm right ninety-six
percent of you know I'm right and only
we more precisely only people like you
can mobilize the movement necessary to
take back this democracy from the
cronies who control it so I'm grateful
for the flash of coolness again standing
on a wired stage
and grateful for the opportunity to ask
you to join us to join us in an effort
to do what everyone says is impossible
to reclaim for we for us for the people
what was promised to us 227 years ago
thank you very much